Hello, in this video we are going to be finishing off the scatter tool.
And to do this we're going to demonstrate exposing a function.
This function is going to allow us to click a button and it will bake out any of the meshes that we have to exist as separate actors within the world.
So again we're back here to the scatter tool.
And for this function I'm actually going to be jumping into the event graph.
So as we go here you can see the event graph. We standardly have the events that were triggered during gameplay.
However I am going to create an extra event here. Right-hand click and search for custom.
And you can see here we have the option for add custom event.
I'm going to select that. And I'm going to name this event Bake Out Meshes.
With the event selected I am going to come up to its details and I'm going to tick the box for call in editor.
And now I'm going to come in and I'm going to add a print string that just says hello.
Compile and save and jump back to the world.
Now if I select my actor you can see here down in the details panel I have a option to bake our meshes.
When I push that button you can see the hello appear in the top left hand corner.
So we know that that's working.
So this is what we're referring to when we expose an event or function.
So call in editor.
Okay so let's delete that.
Now we're going to need to do a couple of things here.
So I'm going to jump back to the construction script.
I'm going to need a list of the meshes that we have created so that we can quickly go through them in order to save them out.
I'm going to do that by adding a new variable.
And that variable I'm going to call MeshesToBake.
And this is going to be of a static mesh component.
It's going to be an object reference.
So I search there for static mesh component.
I'm selecting an object reference.
Now because we're going to have multiple of these I'm going to need to change it to an array.
So up here, drop down, and we're not going to need this to be instance editable because it's a working variable.
We're not going to set it at any point manually.
Now if I drag in the meshes to bake and get, drag off and type in add.
That's going to allow me to add to this array.
And what I want to add is the static mesh component.
So I'll drag off the back of the static mesh component and connect that up.
So you can see what we're doing here.
We're just saving this static mesh component to the meshes to bake.
So we'll have a reference list.
I'm going to compile and go back to the event graph.
I'm going to grab our meshes to bake and get another reference.
I'm going to do a for each.
This is going to allow me access to a for each loop.
And I'm going to connect that up to the event.
So what that's going to do is for every entry into the meshes to bake array.
It will loop, it will action whatever is connected to this execution pin on the loop body.
And this is going to be a reference to the specific mesh.
Next, what I'm going to want to do is drag off and I want to spawn Pacta from class.
It's going to allow us to spawn an actor, drop down search for static mesh, starting mesh actor.
And so this is just going to create a static mesh actor in the world.
And we've got a couple of options here, but the main one we care about is the transform.
Because we want this, when we bake this out, we want this to appear in the place where the mesh was generated.
So in order to do that, I'm going to drag off of the array.
I'm going to type in get world transform.
And so this is going to find the transform of where the component is in the world.
So it's not, we're not going to get the relative transform, we're going to get the world transform.
And we'll plug that directly in.
Now there's only one last thing we need to do. As with any static mesh actor, we need to set the mesh.
So I'm going to drag off and type set static mesh.
It will automatically detect the static mesh component.
And I can connect that up.
And the mesh that we're looking for is here.
So if I drag off of the element again, go get static mesh, you can see it here at the bottom.
Allow me to get the static mesh. And I can plug that in.
So again, what we've done here is we started off with a for each loop for each of the meshes to bake.
We've then spawned the actor and we spawned it by class because you can't, the title can be misleading here.
When you first grab it is going to be spawned by class.
Then we've got the world transform, plugged it into the world transform.
And after that, we have set the static mesh.
If I hit compile and save.
I jump back into the world.
We can now see, I'm going to reduce the numbers down. I'll use this small one for the time being.
If I grab this, if I push the bake our meshes button.
Then we can see that we have singular actors for each of the meshes.
That would allow us to use this as a bit of a stamp rather than having it so that it automatically updates every time that it's moved.
You can just get something that you like.
And then after you've set it up, you can just bake it out.
Great. So that brings us to the end of the scattering tool.
We have it all up and running. Hopefully you've been able to follow that. OK.
In the next video, we're going to be looking at the editor utility widgets.